[Musik]
ein großes tor weist uns den weg immer
weiter ostwärts
es erinnert an die kamelkarawane die
einst ihr auf dieser route der
seidenstraße doch gezogen sind
doch das heutige kasachstan das rund
doppelt so groß ist wie frankreich
italien und deutschland zusammen
ascaron gefahr hat die hauptstraße
verlassen und fährt ihr als bürger sich
auf einer liste befinden würden weite
steppen und wüsten prägen das ganze land
[Musik]
von venedig aus istanbul den kaukasus
haben wir den süden europas und das
kaspische meer geklärt sind eine nackte
im westen kasachstans unser fahrer macht
sich mut indem er sich lautstark mit
einem berühmten deutschen erben
rennfahrer vergleich schumacher
frohlockt er und versucht hier
einigermaßen spur zu halten
v
hier gibt es nicht viel mehr als ein
paar unterkünfte für mensch und tier
etwa ein dutzend leute leben in der
siedlung war schachter von der kamel
haltung und der kamel aufzucht wie immer
am frühen morgen schickt sich die
30-jährige gastarbeiterin gulasch alaba
an die kamele zu merken
noch herrscht ruhe im gehege
die kamele scheinen den tagesablauf zu
können
[Musik]
zuerst kommt das kleine dran und erst
danach wird damit test gefüllt
kamelmilch gilt als besonders gesund sie
enthält mehr molkenprotein etwa dreimal
so viel vitamin c wie kuhmilch viel
eisen und vitamin b wann bp aktie war
hier lange zeit die einzige frau weit
und breit
sie hat die kamelfarm während die haaren
leine geführt und den betrieb erst vor
ein paar jahren ihrem jüngeren bruder
übergeben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier wird ein kamel zum scheren
festgebunden
die wolle der herr krause des kamels
gilt als besonders warm und
strapazierfähig der eingriff schmerzt
zwar nicht große freude aber an dieser
scheint dieses tier nicht zu haben
kamele symbolisieren den reichtum ihrer
halterung cent ihr ganzer stolz
[Musik]
die kamele stehen in einer engen
beziehung zu den menschen die kamele zu
züchten ist ganz einfach nur davon wie
du mit dem tier umgehst dementsprechend
verhält sich das kamel dir gegenüber für
die zucht bringen wir den kamelen sei
dass sie im gehege bleiben müssen
jedes hat seinen namen und es reagiert
auch wenn es gerufen wird auf mich
wirken diese tiere etwas fremd zum teil
auch etwas unheimlich obwohl sie sich
überhaupt nicht aggressiv verhalten
[Musik]
ich werde zum gemeinsamen frühstück
eingeladen alle haben sich hier
versammelt rahn biya bruder seine
familie aber auch die angestellten der
fan t mit frische kamelmilch ich war
zuerst etwas skeptisch aber dass gemäss
schmeckt mir ausgezeichnet
die sci nat mussajew und den chef der
farm freut dass die oft in diesen
ländern in denen sich vieles verändert
sprechen wir über die
zukunftsperspektiven und darüber in
welcher welt hier die kinder und
kindeskinder wohl mal leben werden
was erhoffen sie sich für ihre farm für
die tiere für ihre kinder um ihre enkel
wissen sie kamele sind gute tiere und
auch die kamelmilch von der wir hier vor
allem leben ist sehr sauber und sehr
gesund
wer kamelmilch trinkt dem steht ein
gutes leben bevor
unsere welt wird ja sonst zu sehr von
ungesundem belastet die kamelmilch aber
ist gesund das kamel frist sauberes glas
und gibt saubere milch wie fühlen sie
sich hier in der verlassenen steppe
einfach als bauer oder als typischer
kasache in unserem körper fließt
kasachisches blut wir leben hier mit
einer reinen seele und einen guten
gewissens team durch das ist uns das
wichtigste ich bin ein einfacher bauer
großen reichtum brauche ich nicht
von seiner älteren schwester will
schließlich wissen ob sie es bedauere
dass die kamele als lastenträger und als
transportmittel heute völlig ausgedient
haben
ja sicher aber die technik und die
transportmöglichkeiten haben sich in den
letzten jahrzehnten weiter entwickelt
früher ist hier alles mit kamelen
transportiert worden
aber alles verändert wir passen uns dem
an und unser geschäft die aufzucht und
die haltung der kamele sichert uns mit
dem fleisch und milch die
überlebensgrundlage ich kann nicht
klagen
es sind zufrieden mit unserem leben
[Musik]
im verlauf des vormittags werden die
kamele kühe in die städte freigelassen
die elastische und gemächlicher gang
zieht uns in bann und lässt so beim
betrachten auch in uns selbst eine
gewisse gelassenheit aufkommen
[Musik]
jetzt waren wir aus der steppe zur
hafenanlage von oktay den weg dorthin
weisen und zahlreiche pipelines über die
von überall her im land öl in die hafen
silos gepumpt werden
achim beck am ihr chef ist für den
weiteren ausbau dieser vor allem für
europa wichtigen hafenanlage
verantwortlich immer und immer wieder
während meines besuches klingelt sein
mobiltelefon brach im bett ist ein
gefragter mann und er bemüht sich dies
bei uns gegenüber auch immer wieder
kommt zu tun
schauen sie das sind sie los die je etwa
10.000 tonnen öl aufnehmen werden
und hier hier müssen noch schienen
gelegt werden für zisternen waren aus
denen man später mal das öl ab und in
die großen hafen silos gepumpt wird
welche rolle spielt diese ganze
hafenanlage im geflecht der heutigen
seitenstraße es ist klar
oktober ist in dieser region die
transitstrecke waren die von asien nach
europa und auch in die gegenrichtung
gebracht werden
wir werden waren von china nach europa
und europäische waren für china
ungeschlagen
wir befinden uns hier an einem der
wichtigsten knotenpunkte der aktuellen
der neuen seidenstraße und wieder
klingelt sein mobiltelefon
die sechs thermen wagen rollen an eine
andere stelle auf das hafengelände von
akten und dann von den gleisen direkt in
ein spezielles frachtschiff das ganze
eisenbahnzüge in seinem buch verschenkt
58 zisternen fragen werden hier in das
schiff geschobenen ganze eisenbahnzug
mit dreieinhalb tausend tonnen öl
hier auf dieser inschrift sehe ich dass
der hafen auch noch der europäischen
union in verbindung steht
diese teil des hafens ist ein projekt
der eben welche sich zum ziel gesetzt
hat transportrouten aus zentralasien
über den kaukasus bis nach europa zu
fördern
akt kommt dabei eine schlüsselfunktion
zu dank der eu und europäischen
steuerzahler konnten wir unsere
technische ausrüstung hier ausbauen
unser hafen wurde 1996 auf kosten der
europäischen entwicklungsbank renoviert
seitdem gilt er als der modernste hafen
am kaspischen meer
[Musik]
ähnlich wie in aserbaidschan sind es
auch hier in kasachstan öl und gas
welche den großen reichtum ins land
gebracht haben
ein reichtum der zumindest in den
städten mit händen zu greifen ist
in der so genannten straße der besten
wird an einen der drei weisen aus der
zeit des kasachischen hat erinnert
doch einer fehlt nie an den plakatwänden
des landes langzeit präsident nursultan
nasarbajew
sein wunsch nach einer großen rolle in
der geschichte lässt sich am besten bei
einem besuch in der neuen kasachischen
hauptstadt nachvollziehen in astana
[Musik]
astana eine hauptstadt in wenigen jahren
aus dem nichts gestampft
[Musik]
geld spielt keine rolle gross soll es
sein einzigartig ein denkmal für die
ewigkeit
[Musik]
und er ist einer von jenen die die stadt
gebaut haben
[Musik]
doch an materie kopf
noch vor 15 jahren hieß dieser ort das
weiße grad und es gab hier mehr oder
weniger gar nichts 1997 kam der
präsident mit seinen architekten
[Musik]
die drei wolkenkratzer links heißen die
tanzenden häuser und sind eines der
architektonischen highlights dass shawn
mathey bischof mit seinen kollegen
entworfen hat nach einer besonderen idee
[Musik]
es gibt die in der nähe die sogenannten
tanzenden bäume die sind nicht gerade
sondern haben schlangenlinie stämme also
dachte ich mir unsere häuser sollten
auch schlange für mich sein sozusagen
mit tanzen
das wäre typisch für hier typisch ist
auch das highlight hier oben ihm bei der
eckturm seine hand in den vergoldeten
handabdruck des präsidenten zu legen
bringt glück sagt der volksmund und alle
wollen ein stück glück vom präsidenten
kritische stimmen gibt es hier nicht
wir verdanken unseren präsidenten alles
was wir haben
er ist unser großer vater
er arbeitet an einer guten zukunft für
unsere kinder
er tut alles für sie dafür sind wir ihm
unendlich dankbar
was soll ich sagen gehört unser land
und unsere zukunft der mann den all
dieser menschen zu lieben heißt
nursultan nasarbajew seit 22 jahren
dauer präsident kaz astana
er selbst bezeichnet sich als demokrat
oppositionelle jedoch lässt er gerne
einsperren
er hat vor allem das wohlwollen des
präsidenten zu spüren bekommen eines
präsidenten über den er nur gutes zu
berichten weiß
der kasachische präsident ist ein mensch
der weiter denkt dass alle anderen
ich habe noch nie jemanden getroffen der
so tiefsinnig und weise ist wie er und
der trotz all dieser unglaublichen
qualitäten gleichzeitig wie soll ich
sagen ein so bescheidener mensch
geblieben ist
die neue hauptstadt des präsidenten
bescheiden kann man sie wohl nicht
nennen
der architekt zeigt uns was er
geschaffen hat
[Musik]
von 2005 bis 2007 war shawn mathey kopf
einer der obersten stadtplaner direkt
unter dem präsidenten
heute hat er ein eigenes architekturbüro
und lässt astana weiter in den himmel
wachsen
[Musik]
der prachtboulevard den lieber ich
besonders ganz hinten der palast des
präsidenten
das ist astana
[Musik]
er selbst wohnt allerdings lieber in der
alten hauptstadt almaty nach astana
kommt er nur zum bauen seit 15 jahren
alle haben unser projekt als absurd
bezeichnet keiner hat das für möglich
gehalten
die menschen hatten damals andere
probleme die renten zum beispiel was wir
davor hatten gene allen unmöglich gott
sei dank hat der präsident an seinem
projekt festgehalten
[Musik]
und so entstehen gebäude wie dieses hier
die astana musical entworfen von shawn
mathey back off für die eigenwillige
form hat er eine gute begründung parat
[Musik]
diverse symbolisiert reichtum wenn man
solche vasen aus alten zeiten ebenso
findet sind sie meist voller gold und
münzen
dieses symbol des reichtums passt zu
astana die vase der reichtum
in wenigen wochen ist die eröffnung dann
soll alles parat sein für die reichen
besucher
apropos reich dieser mann ist besonders
reich und entsprechend wichtig für
baumeister matthée kopf ein
geschäftsmann und potenzieller geldgeber
der lieber anonym bleiben möchte über
geld spricht man nicht wo genau am ende
das geld herkommt weiß ich nicht wichtig
ist einfach dass genügend davon da ist
alles kostet geld das land die
projektentwicklung die kommunikation das
bauen ohne geld läuft nichts mit dem
investor redet er dann wohl doch über
geld aber lieber abseits der kamera
einen steinwurf entfernt dem schatten
der prachtbauten das andere astana
hier leben jene die nichts vom reichtum
abbekommen haben
in ihren häusern gibt es kein fließendes
wasser keine toilette
[Musik]
alles ist so wie vor 15 jahren als
astana noch aktuell
das weiße grad und so fühlen sich die
menschen hier auch ich möchte dass wir
auch in richtigen häusern wohnen können
nicht so wie hier mit fließendem wasser
und so zumindest meine kinder und
enkelkinder sollten das erleben dürfen
schaan ist sich bewusst dass er ein
großer teil der bevölkerung vom
ölreichtum nichts abbekommt doch er
selbst konzentriert sich lieber auf sein
neuestes projekt er zeigt im obersten
stadtplaner seiner vision vom astana der
zukunft eine skipiste auf dem dach eines
wohnhauses
das gab's muten der architekt ist
begeistert von seiner vision
[Musik]
pioniergeist pur allerdings nur solange
es nicht um politik geht
[Musik]
ich glaube nicht dass sich ihr politisch
viel ändern wird
und ich will es auch nicht so ist alles
schön ruhig ein gutes klima für
architekten kasachstan hat in der
vergangenheit schon genügend umbruch
erlebt jetzt sollte alles bleiben wie es
ist
johanns vision hat gute chancen
umgesetzt zu werden
astana soll in die geschichte eingehen
zumindest architektonisch
[Musik]
nach unserem ausflug nach astana setzen
wir unsere reise vom ufer des kaspischen
meeres von der stadt aktiv fort und
fahren mit der bahn nach beinahe
schon stunden vor der abfahrt unseres
fernverkehrs zuges herrscht auf dem
bahnhofsgelände von akt auf dichtes
gedränge
ich mache es wie die meisten hier um
decke mich mit getränken und einem
kleinen lebensmittel vorrat ein
eine bahnfahrt in zentralasien wird oft
auch zum kleinen fest seiner art party
mit mitreisenden
die bahnstrecke ist nicht elektrifiziert
und die waggons sind meist sehr gut
besetzt
[Musik]
wer zu steigen will braucht eine platz
reservation und muss sich ausweisen
können wie ich hier mit meinem schweizer
reisepass
[Musik]
unter freiem himmel ist es glühend heiß
eine klimaanlage in den waggons gibt es
nicht und ein
unser nächstes etappenziel werden wir
erst nach mitternacht erreichen
[Musik]
nur ab und zu sind in der steppe kamele
zu sehen und am horizont kleine hügel
tektonischen verwerfungen sonst aber
sonst ist es hier wie fast überall in
kasachstan flach so weit das auge reicht
man sieht kaum menschen kaum je 1 aus
betrieb herrscht dafür hinzu es sind vor
allem familien die hier mit dem zug
reisen weil die fahrt so lange dort
bilden sich spontane
schicksalsgemeinschaft
man spielt man ist und freut sich auch
zusammen
im benachbarten berghaus in die
platzverhältnisse noch etwas länger in
die luft hier ist stickig die stimmung
aber sie ist gut und auch mein besuch
wird freundlich aufgenommen
woher ich komme ich solle mich doch
hinsetzen die heim vergleich zur schweiz
seit das leben für sie hier in
kasachstan wo etwas am cdu meint der
familienvater ein arbeiter in der
ölindustrie
wir hätten eigentlich alles auch eine
gut ausgebildete jugend aber es fehlt an
arbeit verlassen deshalb viele junge das
land nein wo sollen die denn hin
die meisten jungen bei uns halten es
hier aus stimmten viele ziehen weg
wählen das gelingt den ehemann er glaubt
dass ihn seine frau widerspricht ich
versuche die situation durch ein
ablenkungsmanöver zu retten indem ich
mich der tochter zuwende
was willst du mal werden fraglich
lehrerin
wollen sie probieren
die mutter will ist ob man sowas auch in
der schweiz ist das ist kodak gutes
gebratenes fleisch butter schmeckt
[Musik]
die landschaft kasachstan erinnert an
andré große wüstenlandschaften der welt
doch wir sind nicht im wilden westen
sondern gewissermaßen im wilden osten
[Musik]
immer wieder drückt auf den auslöser das
macht freude auch wegen der
interessierten kinder
[Musik]
heute ist dieser teil der seitenstraße
stärker frequentiert als früher weil die
südliche route durch pakistan verläuft
das sich zu einem geschlossenen staat
entwickelt hat
meinem kollegen meteorit brockes des
trotz zahlreicher hemmnisse gelungen dem
diktatorischen talk minister zuerst
seine hauptstadt aschchabad einen gut
überwachten besuch abzustatten
das bin ich mit brocke reporter des
schweizer fernsehens eigentlich hatte
ich die turkmenen filmen wollen
doch fangen wir meine geschichte von
vorne an
vier monate hatte ich gekämpft um eine
drehbewegung zu bekommen
ein begleiter den ich nicht filmen darf
er ist mein erster bekannter in einem
der isolierte ssten länder der welt
mein programm wird ford gegeben zuerst
die hauptstadt aschgabat
und hier beginnen die probleme damit
dass die polizei den filmen am liebsten
direkt ein ende bereiten würde
gibt es ein problem die sind überall
mein begleiter türkisch wird seine
haltung nicht gefilmt werden zu wollen
später noch ändern im moment zeigte sich
als guter verhandler
wir dürfen weiter
[Musik]
dieser mann hat den überwachungsstaat
etabliert und turkmenistan zu einem der
isolierten länder der welt gemacht zur
paar murat nias oft selbst deklarierter
präsident auf lebenszeit bis er 2006
start
[Musik]
seine kinder wollten die nachfolge nicht
antreten
so könnten ja so auf seine zahnarzt und
gesundheitsminister gurbanguli
berdimuchamedow zum nachfolger auch er
praktiziert führerkult vom feinsten
zum beispiel im nationalmuseum viel ist
hier nicht los
das museum wird wird sich neben der
glorreichen geschichte vor allem dem
präsidenten oder dem beschützer
wer sich gerne nennen lässt
plötzlich taucht ein turkmenischer
kameramann auf und richtet die kamera
auf mich wie ein schatten verfolgte mich
kreuz und quer durch das museum
bis ich am ende persönlich zum interview
vor die kamera gebeten werde
höflich aber bestimmt offiziell heißt es
dass turkmenische fernsehen wolle ein
porträt über mich machen
doch schnell wird klar ich soll vor
allem den präsidenten loben sie möchten
dass ich mich auf den präsidenten
beziehe
ja genau die situation ist heikel
ich versuche mich diplomatisch aus der
affäre zu ziehen
turkmenistan verdiene einen bedeutenden
platz in der welt sage ich zufrieden so
wunderbar die angestellten des
staatsfernsehens sind erleichtert
präsident wird zufrieden sein mehr
reicht erstmal mit dem führerkult in der
hauptstadt zusammen mit meinem begleiter
fahre ich raus aufs land
vorbei am größten geschlossenen
riesenrad der welt geht die reise in
richtung osten
[Musik]
ich darf das nationale zentrum für
klinische reitpferde besuchen
der stolz des landes
das reitzentrum ist ein geschenk des
präsidenten an sein volk
hier haben sich der generalsekretär des
reit verbandes und sein stall junge
bereit gemacht fürs schweizer fernsehen
die acht alten china sind eine der
ältesten pferderassen der welt bekannt
als 10 und widerstandsfähig qualitäten
die der generalsekretär
über alles schätzt der turkmenen haben
denselben charakter wie diese pferde
vielleicht waren wir schon immer mit
ihnen zusammen gelebt haben
wir haben hier ein sprichwort das ist
sehr symbolisch für unsere beziehung zu
unseren pferden das sprichwort heißt am
morgen begrüße als erstes deinen vater
und direkt danach begrüßte sein pferd
als reiter und pferdezüchter hat yusuf
die welt gesehen
die usa großbritannien frankreich immer
wieder musste er bei seinen kollegen
gegen das ankämpfen was er vorurteile
nennt in vielen eu ländern versteht man
unter demokratie dass alles erlaubt ist
wenn alles erlaubt ist kann ein land
auch schnell auseinander brechen
ich denke mit der demokratie muss man
sehr vorsichtig umgehen
auf die unterdrückung der opposition und
politische gefangene kann ich den
generalsekretär nicht mehr ansprechen
beim begleiter türkisch drängt auf
weiterfahrt
er möchte mir einen weiteren schatz der
turkmenen zeigen und der liegt in ihrer
geschichte
jahrhunderte lang war turkmenistan das
drehkreuz der seidenstraße und damit
einer der mittelpunkte der weg
die ruinen des heutigen mary im zwölften
jahrhundert wie heute der stolz der
turkmenen wir sind stolz darauf dass
unser land genau im zentrum der
seitenstraße liegt hier turkmenistan und
die stadt nieren
wo wir gerade sind von hier aus zogen
chile karawane weiter nach buchara
hier sehen sie ein architektonisches
meisterwerk die architekten damals haben
diese wunderbare festung nur aus dem 7er
baut seit 18 jahren bringt last juni die
wenigen ausländischen touristen und ein
paar einheimische zu den highlights der
seitenstraße sie sagt turkmenistan ist
ein wunderschönes land
meine begleiter bleiben beim auto zurück
ich nutze den momentum mit dem
touristenführer anstatt über die
vergangenheit über das heute
turkmenistans zu reden
was hat sich in den letzten jahren
verändert dieses jahr haben die krücken
der zugang zu laptops bekommen wie man
mit diesem modernen wunder computer
umgeht aber eine menge internet websites
werden von der regierung gesperrt
jetzt vielleicht noch aber das wird sich
ändern
das system ernährt und erhält sich vor
allem von einem
und das hat mir mein begleiter türkisch
als nächstes aufs programm gesetzt
er hat ganz
eine autostunde von den historischen
kulturgütern entfernt liegt schwer
bewachtes größte förder veltrup minister
das land besitzt die fünf größten
erdgasvorkommen der welt und die sorgen
dafür dass das isolierte land welt
politisch überhaupt eine rolle spielt
auch hier möchte ich ein interview
führen doch das entpuppt sich als
schwierig niemand will etwas falsches
sagen und antworten müssen vorher
auswendig gelernt werden
mein regime treuer führer türkisch
wandelt sich zum vermittler und
organisiert für mich das was man hier
interview nennt
dank der vorausschauenden klugheit
unseres präsidenten nutzen wir unseren
natürlichen reichtum für unsere
wirtschaft indem wir das gas verkaufen
trotz applaus zucker dem regime treuen
türkisch beginnt das ganze theater
ziemlich zu nerven
[Musik]
zum abschluss meiner reise will er mir
dafür noch mal etwas schönes bieten
zusammen nähern wir uns dem was die
turkmenen dass dubai des kaspischen
meeres nennen
milliarden wurden hier investiert um
innerhalb weniger jahre ein luxus-resort
aus der wüste zu stampfen
asa heißt das lieblingsprojekt des
präsidenten
er persönlich hat es in auftrag gegeben
ein fenster zur welt soll es sein und
touristen aus aller welt anziehen
wir haben eine verabredung zum interview
mit dem tourismus direktor des resorts
sogar eine zusätzliche übersetzerin
wurde uns organisiert nur der direktor
will nicht vor die kamera nachricht wird
mehr von seinem assistenten überbracht
erneut endlose diskussionen einmal mehr
übernimmt türkisch die verhandlungen
sie werden erfolglos sein immerhin
dürfen wir uns die hotelanlage ansehen
und können so zumindest in ruhe die
reportage des turkmenischen fernsehens
über meinen besuch in turkmenistan
anschauen
[Musik]
der tourismusdirektor lässt uns sitzen
dafür habe ich vom hotelzimmer aus einen
freien blick auf das was die turkmenen
immer wieder ihr fenster zur welt nennen
tausende sollen hier in zukunft in der
sonne liegen
turkmenistan die perfekte alternative zu
antalya und mallorca
so sehen es zumindest die turkmenen
[Musik]
mein weggenosse türkisch hat eine
entscheidung getroffen
er will der weisung von oben trotzen und
selbst vor die kamera treten
um so eine hoffnung ausdruck zu geben
zog ministern wird sich für die welt
öffnen und immer mehr menschen werden
hier zu uns nach turin ist ankommen um
unser land kennenzulernen
türkisch ist zufrieden
er hofft dass die pläne des präsidenten
nicht nur für neue hotels stehen sondern
auch für ein neues turkmenistan das
weniger isoliert von der welt sein
dasein fristen wird
zurück von doc minister nach kasachstan
wo wir mitten in der nacht mit dem zug
in der stadt beinahe angekommen waren
hier holt uns unser fahr wieder ab
wir fahren auf einer schlechten straße
ostwärts an den grenzübergang zu
usbekistan einem land das nicht viel
weniger autoritär regiert wird hals trug
minister askar unterfahrt trifft seinen
kumpanen es gibt so etwas wie eine große
familie der seitenstraßen fahrer hier
überlebt wer gute freunde hat das war
schon immer so
[Musik]
der verkehr nimmt zu sattelschlepper aus
der ukraine aus polen aus russland
deutschland
sie transportieren maschinen oder
nahrungsmitteln in den fernen osten
kleider schuhe und teppiche in den
westen
hier stellen sie sich vor dem
grenzübergang nach usbekistan
pasqua halt an ein sattelschlepper mit
ausgebrannter führerkabine
guten tag wann ist denn das passiert am
vergangenen sonntag
moskau
waren sie der fahrer ja ich bin der
fahrer ich war gerade draußen als zu
brennen begann
ich habe kein wasser geholt und am
treffer haben indem beim löschen
geholfen er klar ich habe nur einen
kleinen feuerlöscher mit dem war hier
nichts auszurichten und der aufleger der
frachtraum ist der jetzt leer
nein ich habe deutsche butter geladen
und die ist unbeschädigt das
kühlaggregat läuft noch die temperatur
drin ist in ordnung und das fahrzeug
selbst ist es versichert ich
verabschiede mich und wünsche dem verein
alles gute und viele tage ja noch unter
der glühenden sonne auf einer satz
fahrzeug warten muss er weiß es nicht
mit unserem minivan dass wir an diesen
lasten vorbei am grenzübergang werden
wir uns von oskar von unseren fans
verabschieden
wer sich als kasachische version von
rennfahrer schumacher auf dem langen
rückweg machen werde und wir wir
verlassen hier kasachstan
in unserer nächsten folge bereisen wir
usbekistan buchara er hat uns mit
reicher folklore empfangen
insa markant begegnen wir den
märchenhaften fassaden der berühmtesten
usbekischen koranschulen und in lukas
engagierter kunst welche unter den
verträgen geächtet wurde
schließlich begleiten wir drogenfahnder
in tadschikistan von dort nämlich wird
das meiste heroin richtung westeuropa
geschmuggelt
[Musik]
[Applaus]